hey it's adam from wired i want to give
you a little bit of spatial orientation
for comic-con i know you can see all
this on google earth or whatever but it
looks pretty different on the ground
when you're in the middle of 80,000
convention goers so right behind me now
is the convention center and closest to
us in fact is Hall H that's where the
really huge movie panels usually are the
ones where you know 6,000 people come in
to cheer Doctor Who or Man of Steel
something like that on the second floor
of the convention center all the way
back about as far as you can probably
see our smaller rooms some of the
smaller panels and then even a few big
ones like in building 20 and places
where people sign autographs and where
fans get together it's kind of nuts
upstairs and then behind all that
downstairs is the convention floor so
that's where everybody walks around and
sees the booths from places like DC or
all the people selling comic books back
issues toys everything it is not crowded
really fun full of lights separated by
what looks like about four lanes of
traffic and a trolley track and a bunch
of train tracks is a from the convention
center is the gaslamp so immediately
close to us as Petco Park that's where
they play baseball most of the time but
this time of year you can be chased by
zombies behind that is the Omni that's
where the wired cafe is you're going to
see a lot of stuff in the wired cafe
over the next couple of days pretty fun
I was just there and then behind that is
the gaslamp district now the gaslamp is
full of bars and restaurants and little
shops and most of that has been
basically redressed for comic-con's so
there's signs and people walking around
in costume while there too and of course
that's where most of the food is so
every day at mealtime everybody from the
convention center has to cross all that
traffic and all those train tracks
through one or two just little choke
points guided by cops who may just be
people in costume for all I know to try
to get to where the food is which is
kind of insane and then of course right
behind me now is the hilton bayfront
because all of the movie stuff has
gotten so big that it outgrew the
convention center so now they go in the
bay front and have panels as well as
some art director panels and whole other
meetings that are kind of attached
comic-con and parties that's about the
shape of things on the ground if you
want more coverage you can always check
out wired com thanks